try them out while show Vanderbilt
Hospital is right next door to us here
in Nashville and so we decided that we
would investigate their transgender
Clinic yes they drug and mutilate
children but it actually gets worse
somehow we'll talk about that today also
Rhonda Santos is under criminal
investigation for sending illegals to
Martha's Vineyard what crime did he
commit well none of course but uh
they're claiming he committed one and
Don Lemon brings up slavery reparations
and then promptly gets embarrassed it's
pretty glorious Chrissy Teigen says that
her miscarriage was actually an abortion
and she's just now realizing it how is
that possible and our daily cancellation
the Atlantic has discovered that sex
segregation in sports actually doesn't
make any scientific sense at all all of
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
if you're in search a financial peace of
mind make sure you're not wasting money
on high interest fees because they're
only going to get worse as the FED
continues to raise rates it's important
that you act now you can get a great
deal in as little as 10 days by calling
American Finance and get a free mortgage
review from a salary based consultant no
pressure no obligation no upfront or
hidden fees just have a simple
conversation around custom loans that
can fit your budget better from better
rates to Shorter terms even debt
consolidation options you could save up
to a thousand dollars a month with
American financing you know we're all
looking for ways to save money now and
that's why you have to take advantage of
any opportunity that comes up and one
way you can do that is through American
financing but if you want to get a hold
of them here's the number you have to
call
866-569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 don't waste any more time
call them now at
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls one eight two
three three four nmls consumeraccess.org
so we've spent plenty of time in recent
weeks discussing the horrific unethical
dangerous and barbaric practices of many
hospitals and children's hospitals
around the country all being performed
under the guise of gender affirmation
now the media has frantically insisted
that we have to stop scrutinizing the
medical establishment in this way even
if hospitals are sterilizing and
butchering children the media says we
must not uh we must not offer any
critique because if we do we're guilty
of incitement and even terrorism
so we have to remain silent they tell us
but I've never personally been very good
at following orders especially when
those orders are delivered by the
soulless goblins in the National media
I'm much more inclined to do exactly the
opposite of whatever they say and in
fact all this talk about the
Frankenstein Butchery happening at our
nation's hospitals has made us wonder
about the hospital closest to us here in
Nashville uh Vanderbilt Vanderbilt
University Medical Center is the full
name Vanderbilt we'll just call it for
short over the past several days we have
investigated uh the matter
and now I want to show you what we found
and let's begin
at the beginning as we tell this story
so in 2018
Vanderbilt opened its transgender Health
Center there was an article published in
The Tennessean at the time that
announced the new Clinic quoting its
medical director Dr Shane Taylor who
said that the goal was to quote meet our
patients where they are in their journey
and help them with the resources they
need
but then in a lecture during
Vanderbilt's lgbtq Health Grand rounds
lecture series which live streamed to
Facebook but was viewed by almost nobody
at the time Dr Taylor was a bit more
detailed in explaining the hospital's
actual motivations for expanding into
quote-unquote transgender care in fact
she said that she personally helped to
convince the institution to make the
move based in part because she claims
it's the right thing to do but also in
large part because gender affirmation
surgeries are quote big money makers she
boasted that a phalloplasty which is the
construction of an artificial penis
which is made using flesh cut from other
parts of the body she said those could
be worth a hundred thousand dollars when
you factor in all of the follow-ups that
are necessary
listen
starting in January 1st of 2017 I'm
going to be Affordable Care Act
insurance cover carriers are mandated to
cover medical expenses for Trans folks
um some of our UMC Financial folks in 20
in August of 20 I'm sorry October of
2016 sorry a couple years ago put down
some costs of how much money we think
each patient would bring in and this is
only including Top surgery this doesn't
including any bottom surgery and
um it's a lot of money these surgeries
make a lot of money so female to male
and chest reconstruction can bring in
forty thousand dollars a patient just on
routine hormone treatment who I'm only
seeing a few times a year can bring in
several thousand dollars that requires a
lot of visits and Labs it actually makes
money for the hospital
now these I got from the internet
um but it's from the Philadelphia Center
for transgender surgery which has um
does a lot of surgery for patients and I
just want to give you an idea of how
much these bottom surgeries are making
and this is I think this has to be an
underestimate this is for vaginoplasty
they're saying they're quoting roughly
around twenty thousand dollars for
imaginal costume but that doesn't
include your hospital stay that doesn't
include your post-op visits but doesn't
include
um your anesthesia your or so I would
think that this has to be a gross
underestimate I think that's just like
the surgeons piece of it which anybody
who's ever been in the hospital knows
that that's like
uh and the female to male bottom
surgeries these are huge money makers
again I think this has to be an
underestimate that they're voting around
twenty thousand dollars for a
phalloplasty there's been different
thing but I've read that said it could
be up to 100 000
um Dr lineker who's our surgeon said
that there's entire clinics where the
entire Clinic is supported just by their
falloplasties and that is like a
fraction of the surgeries that they're
doing these surgeries are
labor-intensive they require a lot of
follow-ups they require a lot of or time
and they make money they make money for
the hospital
now profitable though may be there are
some medical professionals who take the
Hippocratic Oath seriously and object to
carving up a person's body in this way
Vanderbilt was apparently concerned that
some of their own staff might fall into
that category so at another grand rounds
lecture in 2019 a woman named Dr Ellen
Clayton who's a pediatric specialist at
Vanderbilt told those assembled that if
they refuse to participate due to their
religious beliefs in these procedures
there will be consequences conscientious
objections are problematic she explained
and those who object really shouldn't
work at Vanderbilt at all listen
if you were going to assert
conscientious objection
you have to realize that that is
problematic
you are doing something to another
person
and you are not paying for the cost for
your belief
I think that is a real I mean I think
that's a real issue so
um
so I think you know so you're so yes
Vanderbilt
if someone has a country to the
objections for participating in this
sort of surgery
if it probably has to accommodate you to
the extent that you can find another
person who can do your job who doesn't
have an objection other things of that
nature but I just want you to take home
that say that you're not going to do
something because if you're a
conscientious assistant because of your
religious beliefs is not without
consequences
and and it should not be without
consequences and I just want to put that
out there we are given enormous
if you don't want to do this kind of
work don't work at Vanderbilt
now is it legal to make those kinds of
threats I mean can she legally promise
consequences for those who exercise
their first amendment rights well
whether she can legally do that or not
she did and the point was made clear
Vanderbilt just got into the gender
transition game and now it is such a
central part of its core Mission and its
business plan that any Doctor Who
objects is not welcome to work in the
hospital at all
yet even with These Warnings Vanderbilt
is is uh would seem to be deeply
concerned that some of the doctors on
their staff
might still
stick to their bigoted superstitions
like you know their belief in human
biology and that sort of thing so to
solve that problem they proudly unveiled
a first in the nation they say program
called trans buddy
so the trans buddy program means that
trans patients are paired up with an
activist from the community who attends
appointments with them
the trans buddy initiative is is there
to quote observe how Hospital staff are
interacting and to ensure that they're
using correct pronouns a trans buddy
volunteer in the clip will play for you
in a second even explains that some
medical providers at Vanderbilt are
unsafe and so they require this form of
a babysitting watch
my name is Sean Riley and I am the
program coordinator for Trans buddy at
the program for lgbtq health at
Vanderbilt University
transbuddy provides trained peer
advocates for transgender patients who
are coming for doctors appointments or
other health care related Services
whether you're looking for something
that's related to Medical transition
such as hormone therapy or something
completely unrelated like breaking an
arm or going to an ENT we are here here
to help support any transgender patients
that come through our doors
the transmitting program was organically
created through the efforts of
transgender people and continues to
consistently be led by trans people in
Middle Tennessee transporting program is
a one of a kind in the nation and
institutions are looking to Vanderbilt
to replicate and expand programs like
ours we're not seeking to find Solutions
often for people's problems we're just
seeking to be there and to accompany and
to be a friendly face
and to be a non-medical face in a in a
place where everybody coming in the room
is going to be a healthcare provider and
and may be unsafe sometimes I'm there to
be um sort of always observing kind of
how Hospital staff are interacting with
individuals and again you know using
correct pronouns or treating the
individual with respect
so this is less a buddy program than a
Big Brother program though of course
they would never use such a gendered
term and we did check and confirm that
Vanderbilt makes their orwellian trans
buddies available to patients of any age
including minors in fact a trans buddy
may help Shepherd a child through many
types of services all provided by the
hospital's pediatric gender Clinic
Vanderbilt administers chemical
castration drugs AKA puberty blockers
and irreversible hormone therapy to
minors though sometime in the last month
or two interestingly enough they removed
language from their website explicitly
advertising this practice we had to look
it up on the archived version of the
website we found it there but not the
current version
yet they may have forgotten to delete a
video from Vanderbilt psychiatry's
YouTube channel back in 2020 which
admits explicitly that they will give
and have given irreversible hormone
drugs to children as young as 13. listen
we can provide gender affirming hormones
on an individual who is on a pubertal
blocker depending on whatever kind of
blocker they've chosen or we have
discussed with them or they can present
to us at a later stage of puberty and
then we provide the gender affirming
hormones previously the endocrine
Society recommended to start these at
age 16 but we all know that would be
delayed puberty right not 16 year olds
don't start puberty so more recently
they did update that to say as early as
14 for compelling reasons so we have
some individuals who have started gender
affirming hormones at 13 or 14 to be
more like their peers again fertility
preservation and consent are very
important to discuss prior to any
initiation
for compelling reasons and I think we
can probably assume that uh they've
never met a reason that was not
compelling to them so after they've
drugged and sterilized the kids
Vanderbilt as explained in this video
presentation by plastic surgeon Julian
winacore and physicians assistant
Shaylin Van Der blowman at that point
they will happily perform double
mastectomies on adolescent girls
so when we when we talk about the wpath
guidelines so in order for our patients
to really successfully undergo these
surgeries we do uh again follow these
guidelines so a lot of times it's for
insurance purposes but again
insurance is kind of follow suit with
the wpath guidelines for the most part
so for any kind of Top surgery we do
require one letter of persistent
well-documented gender dysphoria by a
licensed mental health provider
um we ensure that the patient is capable
of making a fully informed decisions on
their own they're the age of majority
however for a lot of our younger
patients again if they are 16 17 here at
Vanderbilt
um if they have been on testosterone
have a parental consent we're able to do
a lot of the top surgeries for those
patients
hmm so
let's review Vanderbilt got into the
gender transition transition game
admittedly in large part because it's
very financially profitable and it is
they then threatened any staff members
who objected and then enlisted a gang of
trans activists to act as surveillance
in order to force compliance and they
now castrate sterilize and mutilate
children as well as adults while
apparently taking steps to hide this
activity from the public view which is
why we had to sift through web archives
and track down videos not available to
the general public just to confirm all
of this information
we're left in the end once again with a
stark reality that the field of medicine
has been infiltrated and co-opted by
Radical ideologues by left-wing cultists
and LGBT extremists Vanderbilt like so
many other medical institutions has
sacrificed both science and ethics on
the altar of gender ideology
and we who object are labeled terrorists
but that is the desperate tactic of a
system that knows it is being exposed
we can't allow ourselves to be bullied
by those kinds of intimidation tactics
and emotional blackmail
we are confronting one of the great
evils in human history there's no
question about it
and nobody said it would be easy or
painless and if they did they were lying
either way
we have to hold the line
let's get to the five headlines
using the internet without expressvpn
well it's like leaving your keys in the
car while you run into the market for a
snack most of the time you're probably
fine no one's going to try to steal your
car uh well I mean these days pretty
likely that they will and it only takes
once anyway every time you connect to an
unencrypted Network in a cafe a hotel or
an airport any hacker on the same
network can access your personal data so
it's just like leaving the keys in the
car that means your passwords your
financial details Etc it doesn't take a
genius to hack somebody all these guys
need are cheap hardware and access to
YouTube
um my my kid could do well my kids
couldn't do it they've never they don't
know what YouTube is but a lot of kids
could do it expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that hackers can can't
steal your sensitive data it would take
the most experienced hacker with the
best equipment available to get over you
know and then they also by the way need
a billion years to get past expressvpn's
encryption so I think you're probably
pretty safe I like expressvpn because
it's incredibly easy to use I just fire
up the app click one button and and uh
I'm free to troll I mean uh Rome the
internet I should say plus it works on
all devices phones laptops tablets so I
can stay secure when I'm on the go
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com Walsh that's exp
r e s s vpn.com Walsh and you can get an
extra three months free expressvpn.com
Welsh now
so Bexar County Sheriff uh Javier
Salazar in Texas has announced that he
is opening up a criminal investigation
into the matter of Ron DeSantis sending
illegals to Martha's Vineyard and you
may be asking uh
why is a guy in Texas doing this number
one what what law was broken what
evidence is there that a crime was
committed these are all the questions
that you may have and fortunately the
sheriff is here to not answer any of
them let's listen
we are opening up a case uh with an
investigation with regard to the
suspected uh
uh activities involving the 48 migrants
from Venezuela that as we understand it
at this point the facts of the case at
this point are that on Wednesday
September 14th uh here in Bexar County
in the city of San Antonio uh our
understanding is that a Venezuelan
migrant was paid what we would call a
bird dog fee to recruit approximately 50
migrants from the area around a migrant
Resource Center on San Pedro here in San
Antonio
as we understand it 48 migrants were
lured I will use the word Lord under
false pretenses uh on into into staying
at a hotel for a couple of days they
were taken by airplane at a certain
point they were shuttled to an airplane
where they were flown to Florida and
then eventually flown to Martha's
Vineyard again under false pretenses is
the the information that we have that
they were promised work they were
promised the solution into several other
problems they were taken to Martha's
Vineyard from what for what we can
gather for nothing for a little more
than a photo op video op
and then they were unceremoniously
stranded in Martha's Vineyard
stranded in Martha's Vineyard I mean
they were uh it's like you might as well
drop them on a desert island they're
gonna starve to death
now he didn't actually explain and we
could you could keep listening to that
but there's no reason because he doesn't
explain what laws were broken which you
know if you're launching a criminal
investigation then that's the first
thing you should be able to explain is
that we believe this law and that law
and that law were broken that's why
we're looking into it
so this is a criminal investigation
where even the person conducting the
investigation as far as he knows no laws
were broken
there's no there's no Theory here at all
of what laws were broken
daily wire has the response from the
DeSantis Camp says the spokesperson for
Santa's responded to Salazar's remarks
by saying in a statement
immigrants have been more than willing
to leave Bexar County after being
abandoned homeless and left to fend for
themselves uh Florida gave them an
opportunity to see greener pastures in a
sanctuary jurisdiction that offered
greater resources for them as we
expected unless the Massachusetts
National Guard has been to these
individuals they've been provided
accommodations sustenance clothing and
more options succeed to succeed
following their unfair enticement into
the United States unlike the 53
immigrants who died in a truck found
abandoned in Bexar County this June
uh I think that gets the point across
you want to talk about lowering
immigrants well yeah there's there's
there's the way in which immigrants are
lured across the border to begin with
by the kind of policies that this
Sheriff because he's a Democrat
certainly supports
and we know what happens there
has the statement for the San
Francisco's Camp mentions 53 immigrants
it's just one example the many just like
the untold human wreckage that that
there is because of our open borders
policies
wreckage on that side of the border and
this
which has it affected both illegal
immigrants and citizens of this country
and that's all because they're lured
across the border to begin with
um The Promise is that DeSantis made
them was it wasn't it wasn't really
DeSantis making those promises it was uh
it's Martha's Vineyard made the promises
when you declare yourself to be a
sanctuary you're promising to take care
of immigrants and so Santa said well
they said they take care of you we're
bringing you to a very wealthy and very
nice beautiful place where they said
they would take care of you
all of that is totally accurate
so what's really happening here uh well
it's simple obviously DeSantis had a
political victory
with this move
and the Democrats know it so they're
seeking the only remedy they ever seek
anymore which is which is Criminal
prosecution that's their retaliation
that's the advantage when you own the
system is that when you get beat you can
always just try to throw somebody in
jail for it
what crime did he commit well the actual
crime you committed is he embarrassed
Democrats and worse than that he
embarrassed Democrats who live in
Martha's Vineyard and uh those are the
ones you're not supposed to embarrass
so that's the crime
speaking of people getting embarrassed
this is a great moment on Don lemon's
show as it's uh his doomed unfortunately
doomed show as it staggers towards the
end of its of its run a great moment not
for Don Lemon himself
but for anyone who happens to watch the
clip I think it's great so just uh just
watch this
well this is coming when you know this
all of this wealth and you hear about it
comes as England is facing Rising costs
of living a living crisis austerity
budget cuts and so on and then you have
those who are asking uh for reparations
for colonialism and they're wondering
you know 100 billion dollars 24 billion
dollars here and there 500 million there
some people want to be paid back and and
members of the public are wondering why
are we suffering when you are you know
you have all of this vast wealth those
are legitimate concerns
well I think you're right about
reparations in terms of if people want
it though what they need to do is you
always need to go back to the beginning
of a supply chain where was the
beginning of the supply chain that was
in Africa and when that crossed the
entire world when slavery was taking
place which was the first nation in the
world that abolished slavery the first
nation in the world to abolish it it was
started by William Wilberforce was the
British in in Great Britain they
abolished slavery
2000 Naval men died on the high seas
trying to stop slavery why because the
African kings were rounding up their own
people they had them on cages waiting in
the beaches no one was running into
Africa to get them and I think you're
totally right if reparations need to be
paid we need to go right back to the
beginning of that supply chain and say
who was rounding up their own people and
having them handcrafting Pages
absolutely that's where they should
start and maybe I don't know the
descendants of those families where they
died in the high seas trying to stop the
slavery that those families should
receive something too I think same time
it's an interesting discussion Hillary
thank you very much I appreciate it
we'll continue to discuss in the future
it is an interesting discussion he was
so out of his League he was so out of
his league and he knew you could see it
on his face you gotta you have to
actually see the clip just you can see
him it's he's he's subtle but you could
tell he's internally panicking because
he's thinking like this is not the
response I was expecting at all I don't
even know what she's talking about oh
this is someone who actually knows
something about history I I'm screwed
and so he bails out of there as fast as
he can
um and it's uh and it's it's just it's
fantastic
and everything that she's saying of
course is 100 correct uh and I'm I'm
glad you know it seems like there's been
a lot of discussion in recent days and
weeks about slavery
and uh which which maybe doesn't seem
different from any other time because
we're constantly talking about it but
the difference now over the last couple
of uh weeks anyway is that we're
actually talking about
the historical realities of slavery
rather than the cartoonish sort of
version that we give from people like
Don Lemon because usually
you know the media they decide the terms
for the for any for the discussion of
slavery or any any historical evil they
set the terms for it and the terms are
always we're only going to talk about
uh about this evil in the context of um
you know when white Americans and
Europeans were perpetrating that's the
only that's all that's all we're worried
about
it seems like with we had uh Bill Maher
yesterday and now this clip now it's
like we're expanding a little bit we're
finally acknowledging that actually
there's there's more to the story than
just that
and this is not a this is not what about
ISM it's not a gotcha
to point out what was previously an
unspeakable
fact
that the ways the the way that Africans
ended up on the ships in the
transatlantic slave trade is because
they were captured and sold by Africans
and that's the reality I mean for the
most part uh Europeans were not wading
into the interior of Africa
to take slaves and cart them out now you
might be able to find examples of that
but that is that would not have been a
feasible
uh plan in in most cases
and the transatlantic slave trade could
not have become what it was
if that's the way it worked
No in fact you had you had African
kingdoms that were very happy they got
the slaves they gathered them together
as she mentions they had them in cages
sitting there on the beach
waiting for people to stop by and buy
them
so if we are going to talk about
reparations for slavery that should be
part of it
you know we need to know
Who Who Are You descendant from uh do
you descend from a slave or do you
potentially descend from one of the
people that captured slaves and sold
them
of course the problem is that almost all
of us if you trace our lineage back far
enough
almost all of us
are descended both from people involved
in perpetrating slavery and for people
that were from people who were victims
of it
it's almost every single person on Earth
We're descended from both we have both
in our in our blood
so if you can inherit that guilt if you
can inherit guilt and you can inherit
victimhood then we're in a very
confusing situation because we have we
have most of us have both
we have inherited guilt and victimhood
what do we do with that
well I'll tell you what we do with it we
move on with our lives and we live in
the present
rather than trying to cash in on the
sufferings of our ancestors or
sufferings that we did not experience
and it's also true that Not only was
um not only were the British among the
first to abolish slavery I mean it's one
thing to abolish it there are other
places Haiti for example there was a
slave Riot Rebellion
um
but it's not just that the British
abolished it it's that they they went
out they then went out on the high seas
and tried to put put an end to it they
tried to stop it they tried to stop
anyone else from doing it
and they sacrificed their lives in doing
so
I mean they they fought to get rid of
slavery across the entire world
and they did that uh you know against
the objections of
Arab slave Traders African slave Traders
and plenty of white slave Traders too
yeah I think I mentioned before when we
had this conversation a few weeks ago
that uh and there are many stories like
this but
um in particular you know the the Arab
slave Traders were brutal and and
vicious and there are many uh stories
you read about from history where uh
because the you know the British they
were patrolling and and they were
looking out for slave ships and uh if
they were on their way you know if there
was Arab slave Traders and they were out
on the on on this the Seas and they they
saw a British ship coming their way
um they would oftentimes just kill the
slaves and dump them overboard
so they didn't have to suffer the
consequences and they could pretend that
they weren't slavers
so
that's really what makes
Europeans and you know unique in their
relationship with slavery
what makes it unique is actually going
out and trying to free people from
slavery actively
yeah most countries in the world
eventually although some took a while to
do it
especially some countries in Africa and
in the Middle East but most countries
eventually got around to getting rid of
slavery sometimes it's because there was
a slave revolt sometimes they it just it
didn't it wasn't economically feasible
anymore
[Music]
but when you look at the countries that
fought Wars over it
did people sacrificed their lives to get
rid of this institution
well that's what makes the British
unique is what makes America unique
another note I wanted to make too and
I've seen a few people point this out
and I think it's important because
you know we've seen complaints
from Americans about uh well Queen
Elizabeth you know her funeral yesterday
and about all sort of the the pageantry
and all the money that's spent on it and
that's where this conversation started
with Don Lemon
um and we've seen these complaints of
people you know Americans kind of
scoffing at the way uh the British are
are Weeping over the death of the queen
well
if you think that looks absurd if that
looks absurd to you
imagine how it appears to them and to
everybody else in the world or how it
appeared to them when they you know
looked over in America and saw the same
sort of pageantry
and over the top weeping and mourning
over the death of somebody like George
Floyd
okay so yeah I mean they they are
Weeping and and and mourning the death
of Queen Elizabeth
who's one of the most significant
figures of the 20th century
and the 21st
but it's not like we don't engage in
similar kind of theatrics here in this
country the difference is just who earns
those theatrics
so you could take Queen Elizabeth's uh
resume
and all the ways that she contributed to
history and then compare that to George
Floyd who did what exactly nothing maybe
nothing of value with his life
be terrorized and victimized members of
his own community and then he died high
on drugs after trying to pass off a
counterfeit bill
we give him monuments
and he had multiple Memorial services
and funerals and people remember the the
Minneapolis mayor falling to his knees
Weeping at George Floyd's casket
so if it seems silly to you when you see
people doing that for Queen Elizabeth
and you say well they didn't even know
her what are they what are they crying
about
what about hundreds thousands of people
showed up to George Floyd's Memorial in
tears
didn't know him never met him
and if they ever did meet him they
probably would not have liked him
because he was a scumbag Criminal
so just uh
kind of putting things in perspective
there I think we played some clips
yesterday from that 60 Minutes interview
with uh President Biden but we somehow
missed this one I don't know this is the
best one and uh and I don't know how he
missed it but he was asked
about his mental acuity you know does he
have does he have what he needs mentally
does he have the mental tools to
continue to be president to run for
reelection
and here's his answer I think this is an
answer
you are the oldest president ever pretty
good shape huh which leads to my next
question you are more aware of this than
anyone
some people ask whether you are fit for
the job and when you hear that I wonder
what you think
watch me
honest to God that's all I think watch
me if you think I don't have the energy
level or the mental acuity then then you
know that's one thing
it's another thing of just watching and
you know keep my schedule do what I'm
doing I I think that uh you know I don't
want to sit down with our NATO allies
and keep them together I don't have them
saying wait a minute how old are you
what do you what they say you know I
mean it's a matter of you know that old
expression the proof of the putting is
in the eating I mean I I respect the
fact that people would say you know
you're old and but I think it relates to
how much energy you have and whether or
not the job you're doing is one
consistent with what any person of any
age would be able to do how would you
say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
I say it's I think it's I I haven't look
I have trouble even mentioning even
saying to myself my own head the number
of years I know more think of myself as
being as old as I am than fly
I mean it's just not uh
I haven't observed anything in terms of
there's not things I don't do now that I
did before whether it's physical or
mental or anything else
he reminds me it reminds me of like a
drunk guy at a sobriety checkpoint
trying to convince the cop he's sober
and the more he talks it's like dude you
should have just quit
short and sweet when you're in that
position short and sweet give short
answers the more you talk the worse it
gets
you've got Biden like mental acuity come
on no one has more acute acute than this
no one is I'm the most mental man come
on
uh so that should make you feel good
about the state of uh the country's in
good hands
as we see once again the only wire has
this report Sports Illustrated swimsuit
model Chrissy Teigen responded to the
backlash against her as she dared
critics to do your worst after she
recently announced that her miscarriage
was actually an abortion the 36 year old
hit back at negative comments that
started flooding the official Instagram
account of Glamor a magazine that
published Tegan's account or comments
rather about the death of her 20 week
old unborn child named Jack
Tegan took a screenshot of many of the
responses with some calling her a drama
queen and a liar and others accusing her
of trying to stay relevant
she then tweeted the message that read I
knew this would happen and honestly I've
already seen you do your worse so if
this makes you feel better great it
doesn't make me feel worse though the
backlash comes following Tegan's
comments at the proper dailies a day of
unreasonable conversation Summit where
she labeled her miscarriage in 2020 in
abortion
um Tegan shared quite quote two years
ago when I was pregnant with Jack John
and my third child uh I had to make a
lot of difficult and heartbreaking
decisions
when I was pregnant with Jack John my
third child
she's pregnant with I don't understand
that it became very clear about halfway
through that he would not survive and
that I wouldn't that I wouldn't either
without any medical intervention let's
just call it what it was it was an
abortion abortion to save my life for a
baby that has absolutely no chance and
to be honest I never ever put that
together until actually a few months ago
I told the world we had a miscarriage
the world agree with a miscarriage all
the headlines said it was miscarriage
and I became really frustrated that I
didn't in the first place say it was
what it was and I felt silly that it had
taken me over a year to actually
understand that we had an abortion so
this is a bizarre story in many ways and
let me just say to begin with that
um
you know you get this from uh
celebrities all the time especially from
Chrissy from from Chrissy Teigen she's
she kind of specializes in this where
she'll they'll announce something
personal about their lives that nobody
asked them to announce they didn't have
to say it
um but they tell the world
and then people have opinions about it
and they get offended they play the
victim the thing is once you have
presented something to the world
information you didn't have to present
once you've done that then people are
going to have opinions because people
have opinions about everything any any
piece of information someone comes
across they form they have a perspective
that they bring to it and they're going
to have their own perspective
and so if you don't want anyone's
perspective on a personal detail about
your life
don't tell anybody
and that's even more the case when
you're using
a something from your life and you're
injecting it into the to a to a a
contentious subject like abortion so you
are drawing this connection you're
bringing this up to the public
and then you play the victim and also
the hero do your worst everyone making
it's like what do you think was gonna
happen well you knew that was gonna
happen
and it also it doesn't make any sense
now I don't know
I don't know exactly what happened with
uh this this pregnancy and how it ended
I don't know I wasn't there
what I do know though is as she admits
as she acknowledges she announced that
it was a miscarriage and she even if I
remember correctly
there were pictures that that she took
of her cradling her child who was
deceased in her arms and uh she posted
the pictures and said we had a
miscarriage it was terrible thing and it
is a terrible thing you know we've been
through this in my family and it's awful
so that's what we know
and now she says well I I didn't realize
at the time that it was an abortion well
what
how could you not realize something was
an abortion if that's what it was
because
well an abortion is the intentional
direct destruction of the child it's
like you go in and kill the child that's
what an abortion is
and also I've never heard of an abortion
but now let's get now we get very grim
and dark when thinking about this but
have you ever heard of an abortion where
they they kill the child and then
give the child's dead body to you to
take pictures with that that doesn't
happen in an abortion clinic
um so none of this makes sense and
certainly if
if you had the child directly killed
through abortion you would know it
there's no looking back on it two years
later and saying oh you know what maybe
that was an abortion there's there's no
confusion about what's happening
so it seems to me
what has happened here if I'm to make
sense of this and again I I you know we
all are within our rights to try to make
sense of it she's the one who's
presented this to the world she didn't
have to when she did so
it seems to me what's happened
is that
there was a terrible Health complication
with the child
they had to deliver the child
early uh too early for the child to
survive and so and and he died
tragically
um it seems like that's what happened
and that also explains how she we had
the pictures of her holding the child
but that's not an abortion though see
this is the point
that is not an abortion
I mean there there are times that we've
always acknowledged this there are times
when there could be a a medical crisis
in the in the middle of a pregnancy
something that affects the child or the
mother and uh it becomes clear that the
pregnancy cannot continue the pregnancy
has to be ended in order to preserve the
life of the mother that can certainly
happen it's not common it's rare but it
does happen
well if you end the pregnancy
by delivering the child without first
killing the child intentionally that's a
delivery that is not an abortion
abortion by definition is the direct
intentional
physical killing of the child if that
does not happen then there was no
abortion
and if you have to deliver a child early
to preserve the life of the mother
knowing almost certainly that the child
will not be able to survive being
delivered that early that's still not an
abortion
that's the principle of double effect
that is you know you're you're you're
you're you're you're you're taking an
action you're delivering the child not
intending at all to kill the child but
yet that that ends up being a result of
that action but that's not your
intention it's not why you're doing it
you're doing it for a good reason to
preserve the mother's life
so it's an act of preservation
it's not murder
so that is what would make sense of this
to me but then so why are you coming
back two years later and saying you know
what I'm counting that as an abortion
it would really seem like you're using
this terrible tragedy that happened to
you and your child
to make a political point
all right before we get to the comment
section here's a clip um I want to show
for you this this is this is from
Amazon's Lord of the Rings show that has
gone it's kind of gone viral and some
people are talking about it
um I still haven't seen the show
and I don't plan on it because I do
judge it and dismiss it based entirely
on this scene I wasn't excited about
watching in the first place I was kind
of thinking about maybe I'll sit down
and watch it
I saw the scene and on this basis alone
I'm not watching the show I know that
might seem well how can you judge a show
based on one scene I think actually you
can
so let's just go through let's watch
this clip together go ahead and play it
all right so you got four guards in
suits of armor
and they take this girl out of the cell
who's that Galadriel or something
is that her name step forward
did she go oh she's not looking happy
she's looking very intimidating what's
gonna happen they're surrounding her
what's gonna happen now
oh she knows what she's gonna do
oh she pushes the guy away and she slaps
the other guy
now we cut away what's happening
he knew exactly where she was going and
now she's shoving all the guards into a
jail cell
she's very pleased with herself but she
walks off girl power that's girl power
okay
so that's the scene now let's let's go
through this again
she comes out
surrounded by four guards all bigger
than her fully armored
and they go to put handcuffs on her she
pushes one away and then the camera Cuts
away and next thing you know she's
pushing them all single file into a cell
a seller by the way was just closed so
she had to she had to open the cell I
don't know how they cut the camera cut
away for five seconds I don't know how
she did all this in five seconds but but
somehow she was able to physically
defeat four guys that were surrounding
her in five seconds and
shoved them all into a jail cell that
was so she had to open the cell that was
just closer to go and open it and then I
guess with one hand she's opening itself
and with with another hand she's shoving
Four Guys into the cell
but how that were they just waiting
there was like were they were they
sitting around waiting one attack sir
this is what you usually see now this is
a common thing in action films I admit
but but it's even more common if it's an
action scene where the woman what's the
Kick-Ass what we're doing the Kick-Ass
woman routine what you'll find is that
there's some chivalry on the part of the
bad guys because what they'll usually do
is even if there's 20 of them
surrounding her they'll they'll only
attack one at a time and if they get hit
once they're out
so the one guy attack the one goon
attacks gets kicked once in the face and
he and he just lies down he's not gonna
get up again then another guy goes and
another guy goes
very polite
and in this case you got to give some
credit again to the bad guys that uh
they were polite
um not only in not attacking her all at
once but actually when she she opened
the cell door and said getting a single
file line and they did and she just she
just coaxed them in and they they just
walked in
into the cell
that's a wonderful scene yes I on that I
don't you don't need to tell me anything
else about the show and I know there are
good people how could you dismiss the
show it's a one scene now
I mean that scene tells me look it might
be an okay show it might be fine
that's kind of what I'm hearing about
the Lord of the Rings show it's fine
it's a fine show
but fine is not good enough when you're
when your Source material is one of the
great you know works of fantasy of all
time
okay let's get to the uh comment section
I love finding easy ways to support a
healthy routine which is why I'm so
excited about tart charity gummies from
the makers of superbeat heart shoes tart
cherry gummies are an easy way to reduce
inflammation from exercise and support
your metabolic Health these gummies are
made with a clinically studied tart
cherry extract that is up to 40 times
more concentrated than many other tart
cherry extracts just two tart cherry
gummies are the antioxidant equivalent
of 16 ounces of tart cherry juice or 100
cherries formulated by a team of
scientists led by a Nobel prize-winning
doctor tart cherry has been clinically
studied to support metabolic health I
had tart cherry gummies for the first
time the other day after finishing up a
workout and I could really feel the
difference I could tell you that tart
cherry gummies come with a 100
satisfaction guarantee try them
risk-free for 90 days and see how you
feel if you don't love them send them
back no questions asked but I think you
will love them I know I did right now
you can get up to 35 off tart cherry
gummies plus free shipping at my
tartcherry.com Walsh that's my
tartcherry.com Walsh this is their best
offer available anywhere that's my tart
cherry.com up to 35 off mytartcherry.com
Walsh these statements and products have
not been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration these products are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease or condition
JS says not only is this teacher aroused
by the thought of himself as a woman
he's also aroused by the idea of
dragging his kids into his sex fantasy
like a flasher would be this is creepy
uh yeah you're right that's also an
important point with this teacher in
Canada yesterday with the big giant fake
breast that he was wearing to school uh
it's a fetish as we talked about this is
not dysphoria okay this is not like he
he
he sees himself as a woman with um
breast the size of watermelons no this
is just this is a fantasy he likes to
see himself that way
but apparently for him part of the
fantasy is not only dressing this way
but dressing this way in front of kids
and the other point I think I don't know
if anyone makes this in the comment
section we read here but
um it's also relevant to point out this
is a shop teacher
and I can remember shop class when I was
a kid
and there are all kinds of safety
regulations like one of them is don't
don't wear really loose fitting clothing
that sort of thing
so there is no way
that these enormous
hot air balloon size fake breasts are
up to code for the the safety
codes in shop class
so putting everything else aside
how is it at all how is that allowed on
the grounds of safety to wear those
things
in shopclass
there's even a video I think we played
the video yesterday he's showing the
kids how to how to use a he's using a
circular saw
with these enormous fake prosthetic
breasts on
um
Mack Brown says not gonna lie every
single one of my friends back in high
school would have been crying trying to
contain their laughter during every
single class even the ones that ended up
being extremely left-wing there were
just certain things we all agreed were
hilarious back in the distant days of
the early 2000s and Beach ball-sized
fake breasts were definitely one of them
pretty sure we would have all been [ __ ]
feathered and crucified under today's
standards I did have the same question
now
you know you have to you have to put
yourself in the kids shoes here and and
they're in a different environment right
and uh it's not fair that they're put in
this position at all they're it's
obviously really awkward and
embarrassing for them but they're also
in an environment where they've been
told that if they laugh about it then
they're this that's a hate crime and
they could get expelled from school
probably
to deny someone's uh lived experience
and their gender identity so that's the
world that they're in
so we don't blame them for not laughing
hysterically but it is just another sign
of the times
yeah I can only imagine when I was in
high school at the same same time period
early 2000s
a male teacher walks in on one of those
we would not be it would be
in some ways would be the greatest thing
that ever happened because it would we
would not stop laughing about it we
would you would if we if that happened
on your freshman High School it that's
you'd be laughing about that until
your graduation and Beyond
um
and that in fact is the appropriate
response to absurdity
and I know the left would say well
that's bullying you shouldn't laugh at
someone
um no you should
when someone is being absurd like that
and it's a lot of other things besides
absurd it's perverse and abusive and
everything else but it's also absurd and
the appropriate response to absurdity is
to laugh at it we should actually teach
our kids to laugh at it
you should teach your kid I would be if
I had a kid in class if I had a kid in
school
teacher comes in like that
um first I would be proud of my my child
for laughing
if they pointed and laughed and said
that's the dumbest thing I've ever seen
I would be so I would be proud of them I
take them out for ice cream afterwards
and say yes that's exactly the way to
respond
and the next thing time you see someone
dressed like that do exactly the same
thing again that is the correct response
correct
but the next thing I'd be doing as the
parent is I'd be marching down to the
school
and saying get that pervert out of the
classroom
okay no you are not gonna have a teacher
acting out their sex fetish in front of
my my child that's not going to happen
so that's the other question I have
where are the parents here and maybe
they showed up we don't really know but
it is Canada so I have my doubts
I mean every
parent in that school
should have should be showing up at the
school and saying fire that person don't
let them anywhere near my kid again
um
let's see jarcher says that Granny is on
par with rap Legends such as push
sheisty and spot em got em truly
wonderful I would put her I think she's
in the conversation yeah the uh rapping
right-wing Grand pro-life grandmother
from yesterday I'd put her if we're
going to start ranking I know this gets
controversial you start ranking the
great greatest rappers of all time I
also I don't pretend to be necessarily
an expert on the subject but I think if
we're doing a top five you know you got
your purush ice to you got spot em got
em that's my number one and two I'm
putting rapid granny at probably number
three all time
um Takashi 69 he's number four
and those are all the rappers I could
name
the time is upon us for another
backstage which is happening tonight at
6 PM Central 7 P.M Eastern it's about
time because there's uh more news than
ever to discuss if you've never seen
backstage before it's where I get
together with my daily wire cohorts Ben
Shapiro Michael Knowles Andrew Clavin
and God King Jeremy boring I like that
they're they're my cohorts that's that's
the the hierarchy we're establishing
which for this read which is good we
have a Roundtable discussion on the most
burning topics of the day jokes will be
cracked cigars will be smoked Libations
will be imbibed plus will be reuniting
with our good friend Candace Owens who's
back with exciting news and ready to
tick off left us more than ever you
definitely don't want to miss this one
so tune in to join us for backstage
tonight at 6 PM Central 7 P.M Eastern at
dailywireplus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
turbin is a prominent doctor and
Professor who's amassed many academic
and professional accolades he's
published studies and written pieces for
the New York Times Washington Post many
other outlets
he's also a [ __ ] and worse than a [ __ ]
in fact Jack turban merely pretends I
think to be stupid and confused he's one
of the medical community's most
outspoken advocates for child gender
transition he pushes to have children
sterilized and castrated as young as
possible he claims that puberty blockers
are completely reversible which is a lie
he claims that they merely put puberty
on hold which is also a lie he downplays
the risk that children may come to
regret the irreversible changes made to
their body during quote transition he
absurdly insists that refusing to
mutilate or drug a gender confused child
is a form of conversion therapy now if
turbin really believed all of this he
would be he would be a [ __ ] and that's
what he would be but you know it's
simply one of the dumbest human beings
walking the face of the Earth in fact is
what he would be but to focus merely on
the idiocy of the gender ideology
Brigade is to ignore their abject
wickedness Jack turbine may be a
profoundly stupid man but let that not
distract us from the fact that he's also
deeply evil and dishonest
and yet this stupid Bad Evil dishonest
fraud has credentials lots of them what
he lacks in brain cells and integrity he
makes up for with degrees that was
essentially the point yesterday when he
tweeted quote four years at Harvard five
years at Yale three more years at
Harvard two years at Stanford but Karen
has some thoughts about sex chromosomes
now his point is simple how dare you
peons approach him with talk of biology
and chromosomes in the binary nature of
sex
turban spent nearly a decade and a half
in Ivy League schools he knows more than
you
at least he has lots of very expensive
pieces of paper framed and hanging on
his wall declaring that he knows more
than you but in reality of course Jack
turban studied in our country's most
prestigious academic institutions for
nearly 15 years
and yet knows less about biology than my
three-year-old daughter which is not
something he should be bragging about
but this is all the gender ideology side
has going for it they do not have truth
or common sense or rationality or moral
decency their views are so insane that
they won't even try to defend them
publicly they advocate for things that
are so horrific and brutal that they'll
accuse you of incitement Simply for
talking about it
as if to say like we know that this
thing that we're doing is so terrible
that if people see it they're gonna
they're gonna they just gotta
instinctively react violently to it
they try to hide behind the shield of
credentialism hoping that you'll
Surrender Your common sense and submit
to their agenda based simply on their
academic resumes they make wild
indefensible claims and expect that you
will
agree or at least shut up in acquiesce
because they they have letters after
their names and you don't
they try to make very simple things seem
very complicated so that you will be
convinced that only Scholars and
academics are qualified to discuss them
and that brings us finally to a recent
article in the Atlantic titled
separating Sports by sex doesn't make
sense
yes author Maggie Mertens in the
Atlantic has declared that the thing
which made sense to everyone everywhere
since always actually doesn't make sense
at all and she will list a couple of
academics to help convince you hoping
you won't notice how stupid they all
sound so she writes quote
School sports are typically sex
segregated and in America some of them
have even come to be seen as either
traditionally for boys or traditionally
for girls think football wrestling field
hockey volleyball however it's becoming
more common for these lines to blur
especially as gen's ears are more likely
than members of previous generations to
reject a strict gender binary altogether
yeah I wonder why gen Z is rejecting a
gender binary could it be because
they've been told from birth that there
is no binary
we often hear this from the left I mean
I heard it when we were filming what is
a woman we got this a lot that um well
look at gen Z you know they get it there
let's follow their lead they're taking
the lead on this
but first of all I'm not inclined to
follow the lead of the generation that's
been on this planet the shortest amount
of time and knows the least about it but
also gen Z is only following they
themselves are following the lead of the
people who indoctrinated them
so the indoctrinators are indoctrinating
gen Z and then turning around and saying
look at that gen Z they get it I mean if
they're if they can see it then why
can't many all you people
well it's because they're just parroting
what you told them
continuing it says maintaining this
binary in Youth Sports reinforces the
idea that boys are inherently bigger
faster and stronger than girls in a
competitive setting a notion that's been
challenged by scientists for years
decades of research have shown that sex
is far more complex than we may think
challenged by scientists what scientists
now Merton's links to a study that she
of course assumes nobody will take the
time to read
it was co-authored by a woman named
sarri Van Anders who just is described
in her online bio as quote a leader in
feminist bioscience along with Zach
scudson who's a doctoral student in
women's studies so these are the people
two other authors on the on the study as
well with similar credentials
but the study itself says nothing proves
nothing and simply talks in circles
often contradicting itself
for example it begins by establishing
that sex and gender are quote
overlapping yet they are distinct
categories
but then the study ends with this
sentence in their conclusion
one may therefore question the use of
biology to justify ongoing segregation
by gender slash sex because biology does
not support a gender binary and instead
highlights that sex is multifaceted
wait
biology does not support a gender binary
but highlights that sex is multifaceted
but you those are two different things
you just you said those are two
different categories
see this is the trick gender and sex are
two different concepts in one moment and
the next they're used interchangeably
it's all nonsense meant to confuse
rather than enlightened enlightened they
can't prove any of their assertions but
they can attempt to make you so confused
that you just give up and stop
challenging their ideas
the article continues quote and those
sex differences in sports show
advantages for men researchers today
still don't know how much of this is to
is it is attributed to biological
differences versus the lack of support
provided to women uh to reach their
Highest Potential
quote science is increasingly showing
how sex is dynamic it has multiple
aspects and also shifts for example
social experiences can actually change
levels of sex related hormones like
testosterone in our bodies in a second
to second in month-to-month way Sarah
van Anders the research chair and social
neuroendocrinology at Queen's University
in Ontario told me by email
the insistence on separating sports
teams strictly by sexist backwards
argues Michaela Musto an assistant
sociology professor at the University of
British Columbia who has studied the
effect of the gender binarian students
and young athletes quote part of the
reason why we have this belief that boys
are inherently stronger than girls and
even the fact that we believe that
gender is a binary is because of sport
itself not the other way around she told
me by phone the strict sex segregation
we've instilled in sports at all levels
gives the impression that men and women
have completely different capabilities
but in reality she said the relationship
between sex and athletic capability is
never so cut and dried
so this is what they're going with there
are no inherent differences between the
sexes
but if there are it's only because of
social conditioning it is social
conditioning which makes men on average
faster stronger quicker
social conditioning gives men better
endurance
I suppose we can assume that social
conditioning also makes men taller
I mean it's one of the that's one of the
reasons they have an advantage in some
sports like basketball is that on
average they're a lot taller is that
because of uh of women haven't had the
support they need from society to grow
taller
there are literally hundreds of physical
differences between the Sexes it's not
just a matter of testosterone levels the
differences Encompass height weight bone
density muscle mass Etc
all of these differences give men the
edge in competitive sports are these all
social conditioning
is it a lack of support in athletic
programs that leads to women having
lower bone mass
thus by the way making them more
susceptible to injury
does that also explain why similar
physical differences between males and
females can be observed in the animal
kingdom especially among mammals
see this is the the thing that the
people who challenge the sex binary
always ignore
they ignore nearly all of the other life
forms on the planet I mean at one moment
they're quick to remind us that oh we're
just an animal like any other
you know we're nothing special
but then when it comes to biological sex
they put us in a completely different
we're the only species it doesn't have
biological sex they never deny it in any
other species
and all of these facts which they ignore
help to explain why a group of talented
Middle School boys could dominate a WNBA
team why the fastest woman at the
Olympics has never been faster than the
fastest man at the Olympics in any race
or event ever in history
why men dominate women athletically in
nearly every measurable category in
nearly every sport and always have since
time immemorial why in fact every human
society since the dawn of man has
organized themselves around a
recognition of the difference between
the Sexes and as tasked men with taking
on the more physically challenging and
dangerous roles now it's not that that
men are conditioned that way it's that
they are this way they are bigger and
stronger and societies have recognized
that and utilized those characteristics
in a way that makes sense
which is why you go all the way back uh
to to you know primitive times and what
you're going to find is that uh in most
cases the men are going out hunting and
the women are at home taking care of the
home
um you you aren't going to find cases
where it's flipped around and the men
are the Homemakers and the women are the
ones who go out hunting that wouldn't
make any sense because every society has
noticed well these are the bigger
stronger people with more endurance and
so obviously they should be doing that
we're the only ones who've been confused
about the subject
only we're not really confused the truth
is still plain as day
it's just that the difference is that
now we have a whole Army of Highly
Educated quacks and frauds trying to
make us confused
that is why they and especially
whatever her name is I forget her name
now at the at the Atlantic are today
canceled
and that will do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]